So, that's the normalized cut approach,
and it's one of the more
effective methods within the whole
graph-based way of doing segmentation.
The pros are because
it's a graph structure,
we've got lots of algorithms for
dealing with craft structure.
So, it's a very generic way of doing it,
because you separate out
this graph structure question from
the affinity matrix computation.
So the affinity matrix is where
you get to play with things,
like your distance functions,
and your feature spaces.
And then, your graph algorithms just
run given that that, that matrix.
So again, it doesn't require
a model of the data distribution.
It just requires a distance
function that respects that.
There are some challenges.
In general, the complexity of dealing
with this can be pretty high,
because you now have this, these
matrices that are essentially n by n,
where n is the number of pixels.
So you want to be careful exactly
how you manage that complexity.
If you have densely connected graphs,
because you want to allow for
large regions, et cetera the system
has to work even harder.
And the, the spectral decomposition
approximation to the normalized cut
is a little bit trickier to do.
And, and then there's this question
about this balancing of the partition.
So you remember, we introduced
the normalization to the min-cut,
in order to not get small pieces,
because there was a bias towards
small pieces in the algorithm?
Well, another way of thinking about this
is, we've introduced a preference for
balanced partitions,
for balanced regions.
So if you really wanted to have small,
little spots being pulled off of
something that was bigger, normalized
cut finds that kind of painful,
because it wants to have
these balanced partitions.
Having said that, I will say that
it is one of the more effective
segmentation methods that
people currently use.
And I think it's because it has
this nice dissociation between
the affinity matrix computation and
the graph segmentation method.